[موسيقى]
في الواقع بالنسبه لك طفله عندما كبرت
عرفت ان الولايات المتحده هي التي نفذت
الهجوم هي وجنود من فيتام الجنوبيه الذين
كانوا يقاتلون فيتنام الشماليه عندما جاء
الجنود الشماليون ليحتل القريه نصق ضباط
الجنوب مع الولايات المتحده وابلغوهم
بوجود اولئك الجنود الاعداء هذا ما حدث لم
ارى هويه قائد الطائره في الحقيقه ولكن ما
عرفته لاحقا ان النظام كان سلاحا متوفرا
فقط لدى الولايات المتحده هذا ما اعرفه
[موسيقى]
عندما انتشرت الصوره كنت في المستشفى ثم
لم عدت الى قريه اراني والدي اياها وقال
لي هذه صورتك مثل ما شرحته لك فقط سالت
والدي بغضب لماذا التقط صوره هكذا ولماذا
نشرها في الوقت الذي كنت عاريه مع شقيقي
واقاربي لماذا لم يتفهم هؤلاء لم تعجبني
الصوره بتاتا ولم ارغب في رؤيتها مجددا
لفتره طويله لمده سنوات
الفيتناميه وقتها انني انا صاحبه الصوره
التي جارتنا نقولها على صعيد واسع في
العالم ارسلت وفدا يبحث عني في المدرسه
والمنزل ومن ساعتها بدات تستخدمني وتضغط
على اسره لاستخدام في دعايتها السياسيه
بالنسبه لي كانت حقيقه منعرج سيئا في
حياتي في الب اعجبني ذلك وخاصه كوني فتاه
صغيره عاديه من قريه مجهوله تذهب الى
مدرستها بجروحها والامها وعذابها وفجاه
تسلط عليها الاضواء وتصبح محل اهتمام
الحكومه لكن لاحقا اصبحوا الامر مزعجا
[موسيقى]